You might not think dogs would be allowed into a hospital. [Griffin] "Our dogs have to be washed, cleaned
and brushed and everything.”
We recently met up with Ellen Griffin and Gerry Serotte,
two dog handlers who volunteer for a dog therapy program called Happy Tails Pet Therapy.
On this day the dogs were visiting patients
in Emory Saint Joseph’s oncology unit.
[Dexter] “The program started small.
One of our managers approached me and asked me if I was in favor of doing it, and I said ‘absolutely.’”
Hospital CEO Heather Dexter knows from firsthand experience the comfort a
therapy dog can bring to patients and their loved ones.
“My brother was in a bad car accident many years ago and was in a coma for almost a year,
and during that time we had Happy Tails dogs come into his room. And I remember —
he was in a coma he wasn't responding a significant amount — when that dog came in,
you could see him relax, you could see him engage a little bit with the world around him,
and I would also notice that my parents would relax. And it was a moment to give them a little bit less
stress and something to look forward to in the hospital.”
Dexter's brother never recovered from his injuries but his own pet golden retriever would go on to become a comfort dog.
“My mom decided to honor my brother's memory by training his dog for Happy Tails,
and so his golden retriever was actually a Happy Tails dog for many years after his death.
Happy Tails dogs started visiting Emory Saint Joseph’s in 2011.
[Griffin] “We had a team of two dogs and we visited in the radiation room and in the infusion center
and through the years it's gotten so popular that we now visit seven areas in the hospital
and I have about 30 dogs involved in the program.
A lot of times we go in and the patient is just down, I mean not smiling, very depressed,
and we’ll say, “Would you like to meet our dog?” and they'll look like ‘Maybe… maybe not.”
And I’ll say “Well, just let Amy come in for a minute,” and by the time we leave they're laughing,
they're talking, they're interacting with us. And that's just what we do — we try to brighten brighten their day.”
And the dogs also brighten the day of the medical staff.
[Serotte] “It also changes your life. I mean it's made my life bigger and my heart fuller,
I'm not the same person.”
[Dexter] “They bring joy, so that helps with the healing process, but they also bring normalcy, and it gives them
something, it gives them some sense of a stress-free environment, some balance and ultimately joy.”